-Welcome back to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
We have a lot more show
coming up.
I was going to, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm sorry. Cher?
Cher, what are you...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Cher, what are you...
W-What's going on?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God! Cher!
What is happening?!
-[ Laughs ]
-What are you doing here?
Cher!
-Ahh.
-What are you...?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you. Thank you.
-She's...
-Thank you. Thank you.
-Cher...
-Thank you.
-What? What?
-What?
-What are you --
What are you doing here?
-Because -- Have you forgotten?
It's our 35th anniversary
of our show.
Is it thirty -- Wow. Already?
-Yeah. Oh, you guys probably
don't know this, but --
but he and I actually
were on a show together.
-Yeah, back in the day, we --
there was a show
called "Point..."
Here. Come. Sit closer.
-Sorry.
-There was a show called...
-"Point Pleasant
Police Department."
-Yeah.
-And it took place in lovely
Point Pleasant, New Jersey.
We played two detectives...
-Right.
-...who couldn't see eye to eye.
We'd get in a lot of arguments.
-Yeah.
Now, this sounds
like it's a joke,
but this was very serious.
It was a serious show.
-It was a drama, yeah.
The two cops
would get pretty heated
and always seemed to end up
in messy situations.
Oh, my goodness.
We actually have a clip
from one of the episodes.
-No!
-I'm just hearing. Yeah.
Let's take a look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Oh.
-Morning, Pete!
Punctual as usual!
-[ Laughs ]
-Good morning, Pam!
You seem pretty perturbed!
-I am pretty...
perturbed!
But what's --
what's the problem?
-Well...
-I put in a transfer because...
Lieu-- Lieutenant Palmer
promised to put me on probation
if I'm not punctual!
-P-Puh -- Puh --
-What? What? What?
No!
-Don't be pugnacious!
-Stop.
Would you like some oatmeal?
-Well, you -- Oh, be careful.
[ Giggles ]
Oh, no.
Don't be pugnacious, Pete!
Oh.
-No. That's when you spit.
You don't spit...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's more intense
than I remember.
I forgot that you --
I forgot now.
Thinking back of the show,
I forgot your character
had a mustache.
I didn't know that.
-No, well...
-I think someone
made a mistake maybe.
-Uh, it was very in-your-face.
-Actually, that was the slogan.
It was very in-your-face.
I'm hearing we have
another clip.
[ Laughter ]
From the same episode?
Check this out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Pete!
I'm in a...
pretty...
...pickle!
[ Laughs ]
No, I'm in a pretty pickle,
Pete!
-Why?
-Because I heard
you're pretty passionate.
-Yeah. What?
-And I'm pregnant!
And you're gonna
have to take a...
paternity test...
to prove -- Oh, [bleep]
[ Laughter ]
-Stop.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You keep the language up.
this show's gonna get canceled!
-Um...
-I'm positive I'm not the papa!
-Pipe down! Pete!
[ Shrieks ]
Oh. Oh! Here. No.
-Go.
[ Clattering ]
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cher laughing ]
-Perhaps...
you could provide some...
particulars to point us at
the person we'll pursue.
[ Laughter ]
-You know what I think
about that?
-Oh, God.
I know I'm gonna find out.
-[ Shouts ]
-[ Shrieks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-You could really feel
the emotion.
You could really feel
the emotion in that scene,
I thought.
-I could almost taste it.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, you're kidding me.
We have one more clip?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, God! [ Laughs ]
-This one --
This one is from the famous --
the famous Christmas episode.
-Oh, God.
-Yeah.
In this one, the tension
really just comes to a boil
and things get out of control.
Let's check this out.
-Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Yeah.
Another successful year of...
protecting Point Pleasant!
-I'm no prognosticator.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm...
You pricked your finger?
-Yeah. I did.
-Your little pinky?!
[ Cher laughing ]
-Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
-Uh-huh.
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay.
-Alright.
-[ Shouting ]
-[ Shrieks ]
[ Cher laughing ]
-Ooh.
Almost swallowed
my 'stache there.
-I know.
-Yeah, I --
-Pretty.
-[ Stammering ]
That sounded like it started
with the letter "B" there.
I didn't...
-Mnh-mnh.
-No? It wasn't "B"?
-Pretty.
It was --
It was, um, parfait.
I was about to be parfait.
-I just want to say...
-What?
-I think you're perfect!
-And I think
you're perfect, too!
-Merry Christmas, partner!
I'm glad we're part of the...
Point Pleasant
police Department!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Pretty good policemen.
-I'm proud of the performance.
-My thanks to Cher, everybody.
Her album, "Christmas"
is available everywhere now!
Stick around. We'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show."